Hey YouTubers! It's Charlie. So this is going to be my Gotham episode twenty video.
If you didn't know there's two more episodes in the season. We're that close to the finale.
There's next week, and then the week after that is the last episode.
Originally I'd thought that this was going to be the conclusion of the Ogre story line but that's
spilling over into next week so that's going to be a three part story line with his character.
I feel like we were all in agreement this week that the Riddler was probably the redeeming quality of this episode.
He's consistently the most fun thing about this show.
Fingers crossed in season two that they spend a little bit more time in each episode with his character.
They can do that. They can course correct like that if one character just becomes
vastly more popular than the others.
it doesn't always happen because
sometimes they've already made the episodes so it's too late to change.
One of the good things about Gotham right now though is they've been picked up for season two so they have another twenty-two episodes
and they haven't even started writing it yet  so they can look at the characters
that the audience has been rallying behind and just
spend more time developing those characters.
So let's just go ahead and get into it. Careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet. Starting with top five moments.
Number five: Barbara is captured by the Ogre.
I don't know if captured is the right word because she did go willingly.
That's kind of his MO. He just charms them into his sex dungeon.
It's like Fifty Shades of Gotham right now.
I couldn't remember but I feel like the sex dungeon was actually in the promos.
I feel like that's a promo moment that they would show off.
There are only a few things that pass through your mind when you see a shot like that. One you think
Fifty Shades of Grey sex room,
or two you think of Jigsaw with the Saw movies.
Like classic Texas Chainsaw Massacre type horror.
I feel like the crazy torture room would actually be the more preferable option just because Fifty Shades of Grey was such a terrible movie.
It'd be more fun if they were going for more outright comedy but that's not what they're going for with the Ogre story line.
He's meant to be very threatening and very scary
even though he's coming off more like a Tim Burton villain
you know one that you laugh at.
There are a few exceptions to that. I feel like Danny Devito
balanced the line between funny
and terrifying really really well.
The ogre story line is really the backbone of this theme that's been crossing these
I guess these three episodes you can call them now.
People killing to save those that they love.
Is Gordon going to kill the Ogre to save Barbara, even though they're estranged?
Short answer: yes. Even though we don't know if the Ogre is actually going to die.
We can say he'll probably commit to killing the Ogre
to save Barbara whether or not it actually ends up going down that way.
Comic book shows have a way of saving villains like
they find some out so they could always come back in a future season.
What I'm really hoping to see out of this Barbara/Ogre story line
is like a dramatic character shift in Barbara.
I haven't felt like her character has been very interesting and I feel like
they could use this trauma, this Ogre trauma,
to take the character in a different direction and just have a little bit more fun with her.
On to number four: Bruce and Selina go on a super special date to try and do some super sleuthing.
Here's the thing about all the Bruce and Selina stuff:
This was a lot of fun like I really like their moments together but I feel like
they work better on a show say like The Flash that
plays more on lighthearted comedy.
I feel like children just work better in that context.
Unless it's going to be some crazy horror flick and that's not really what Gotham is.
The thing I really like about Bruce and Selina is that Selina
is probably the strongest female character on the show
and she's the youngest which is just hilarious.
She's kind of the brains of the operation even though Batman becomes the world's greatest detective.
She's the one that always knows what's up.
I think she made her feelings for Bruce pretty clear when she pushed Alfred's friend out the window.
That's kind of like her version of what's going on with the Ogre.
People crossing the line to save people that they really care about or love.
I don't think that Catwoman loves Bruce, like their relationship isn't that intense yet.
Moving on to number three: The Penguin vs Maroni.
So if you remember the last episode he's just working his way up to just
getting rid of Maroni
but we also have Fish Mooney that's coming in from left field too.
We're so close to the finale
that all of the mob elements of the show
are going to turn on each other and go crazy in a Battle Royale.
I feel like the show is just backing the Penguin
as the protagonist of this story line.
Even though he is one of the more notable batman villains.
I don't think of him as an antagonist on the show.
The show wants you to root for him so that makes him a protagonist.
Yes Jada Pinkett Smith did spoil a few things that might be going down in the finale so
let's just not mention them in the comments or if you do please use spoiler tags.
I feel like if you've been frustrated with the Penguin's story line
you'll be really happy with what goes down in the finale
like he'll get his really bloody gruesome moment.
He's killed a lot of people this season.
Arguably I think it was a bigger WTF when we saw the Riddler kill someone because he'd never done it before.
Once you do it the first time each subsequent killing becomes less and less of a WTF unless they're killing a character that you love.
Most of the people the penguin has killed have been third rate henchmen so it's not that big of a deal.
You could argue that Maroni was trying to cozy up to his mother
so he's trying to kill someone to protect a woman that he loves
just like the other characters in the show.
With the exception of Bruce and Selina where you can flip the gender roles.
On to number two: Barbara drinks a little bit of the Ogre Kool-Aid.
There's a certain part of me that feels like she almost went into that
torture dungeon willingly so
you just wonder what's going through her mind.
If you've been watching Daredevil
the Vanessa character is like this
really complex interesting female character that
seems like she's evil but she's not.
She enters into this really twisted relationship with the main villain
but she doesn't canonize him. They have a very loving relationship.
So you wonder what is going on inside her head. It's just fascinating to me.
I feel like this Ogre story line could be a redemption for Barbara's character.
I feel like there's a couple logical ways that it could go down.
You could play it straight
Gordon saves her and they jump starts their relationship and just try to deal with the trauma.
That's like the safety option. I hope they don't go that route.
The second more interesting option is
that it pushes her over the edge and she goes super dark.
Originally when they were conceiving the show the Barbara Kean character
was actually a different character. They changed it just a little bit.
I think she was originally intended to be
something of a proto Batgirl like
that might be where she'd end up in four or five seasons.
The actress that they initially cast as that character
they ended up firing.
The actress you ended up seeing as Barbara Kean right now
that's the person that they brought on after the fact so I think they changed her story line.
I don't think this Barbara is going to turn into Batgirl or anything like that.
It's way too soon even if they are going to do that.
Usually what you see is a character go through some crucible like some
really traumatic experience. It changes them
and they find new purpose.
That's kind of what I'm hoping happens with Barbara.
I'd really like to see her go off the rails in season two because of this experience.
This experience drives her in more of like a Black Canary direction
where she decides to fight back.
Would that not be so crazy if Barbara went off and joined the League of Assigns?
Never gonna happen
just somebody on Tumblr can take care of that FanFic.
Moving on to my number one
WTF moment:
Arguably the most redeeming moment of the episode,
the Riddler kills Ms. Kringle's boyfriend in the heat of passion.
I say it all the time. He's the most fun character on the show.
I don't think this is going to drive him to villainy just yet.
Let's think about this. He just killed someone.
He is completely freaked out. I loved his reaction too "oh dear".
He has some of the best comedic timing on the show, especially with the watermelon.
If he tells Ms. Kringle there's only a couple ways that she could react.
One, most likely, she'll probably freak out
and it drives him away from the police station. I feel like it's a little too soon for that.
So he might not tell her right away. He'll probably try to cover up the murder.
That might give him the opportunity to grow closer to Ms. Kringle.
I want to see those characters together, their scenes are so much fun.
I would really love to see her go dark. Some sort of Stockholm Syndrome where she
becomes a slightly evil character and they enter into this
quasi-crazy Joker/Harley Quinn relationship.
The Riddler is not quite ready to be a villain yet. He's just not at that point.
So I don't think that's going to happen right away.
What I'd really like to see is him
finding some clever way to cover up this murder and
he'll find new confidence in that so
when he's presented with a similar situation in the future
he won't hesitate to kill someone.
It's like the slippery slope to villainy.
He'll just slowly find it easier and easier to do what he wants vs. what's right.
I feel like we can't call him a villain until he outright starts committing crimes
for pleasure and leaving classic clues.
Everybody keep your eyes peeled though for clues with respect to this specific killing.
Here's my big question for you guys though: He just killed this cop.
Do you think he's going to leave a classic "Riddler clue" as part of the cover up that he generates?
There have been so many classic Riddler moments. I feel like they have to do that before the season is over.
Also this is the biggest thing that's happened to his character so far.
Also really fun Easter egg. If you guys didn't notice it,
the actor that was playing the Ogre's father, this old actor here
He was Moriarty on Star Trek: The Next Generation.
Think about that. I feel like it's so appropriate to cast him as this role here.
The father of this really evil person.
Here's a really quick update on the video schedule for the next couple days. It's going to be a little bit weird because
I'm catching a special screening of Avengers: Age of Ultron tonight so my Flash video is going to post a little bit late.
So next I'm posting my Flash video. That will just post late tonight
so be sure to subscribe to get it.
Then Tuesday morning I'll post a non-spoilery Avengers: Age of Ultron review.
Don't worry I won't spoil any of the credits or any of the big stuff like that.
It's just gonna be a lot of fun.
You can follow me on Twitter and Facebook for updates
on videos after that.
I have to figure out when I'm going to post Agents of Shield and Arrow so
I might shuffle those videos around a little bit too.
Then after that I'll try to get through my Daredevil
stuff. There's just a few more Daredevil videos I need to post.
What I'm going to do with my spoilery Avengers: Age of Ultron review
is just wait until after people in the United States see it
because that won't be until after May 1st so
after that I'll post my Easter egg videos, full spoilers,
and stuff like that.
If you don't know where my Twitter and Facebook are, there are links in the bottom of the description for that.
Don't forget. Really big episode of The Flash tonight.
While you guys wait for that you can
click here to catch up on all my Flash videos
and you can click here for all my Avengers/Marvel videos.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody lets high five. I'll see you guys tonight.